hello it's me Markiplier back at it
again with this game one of my favorites
just decided to try it again
it's just because it's been a while and
I feel like it's time for me to play it
again that's all my voice didn't crack
and oh oh look at the DLC oh [ __ ]
look at this we get to explore the story
of rose and you all know rose rose Ethan
Winter's daughter
the story continues the power that she
has and that's all that I'm here for
okay
okay I'm just enjoying the day
you said you had something important to
tell me I hope it's not about Chris
wanting me to join his operation because
I already told him that's not happening
see what he puts you in the rest of his
Hound wolf Squad through oh thank you
it's not about that
it is about you
me
I
if I worry about you
I always um
how are things at school
seriously that's what you wanted to talk
to me about thank you I mean girls still
haselania
I mean are they still
free hey
look at me you're not a freak
um
you know I am
that's why I keep my distance from
everybody at school
they knew what I really was
so
you don't have any friends that you can
talk to
talk to about what
I'm hardly even human how I'm
some kind of horrendous monster
that hey it's okay
I hardly ever murder my friends if there
were a way hardly hardly get rid of your
powers
and get rid of them in a heartbeat
all right well
I think there's something I need to show
you
not your powers also what do you mean
about you hardly kill your friends
Miranda and them you to my seat how she
researched it obsessively and perform
experiments on human subjects oh I'm
sorry what like me wait a minute what
exactly uh well you don't mother Miranda
is that we recently found some of her
research apparently she discovered a
purifying Crystal that can remove the
mutomycity from its host
purifying Christmas you can get our
hands on one of these we might be able
to weaken or remove your powers and
tires are you talking like a JL Crystal
no no but her notes are incomplete
however
I think I have an idea where we can find
the rest of her research
just find it where is it uh
in there
what that's a fragment of the mega mice
heat it absorbs and stores memories from
people who pass away in close proximity
including Miranda and everything she
knows
if you enter its Consciousness you might
be able to solve the mystery of the
purifying Crystal why wait what do you
mean enter its consciousness
Okay so
you
you're
deep connection
will allow you to
explore the information Within
crazy
you sound crazy I concur
it's Rose but not dangerous
right think of it just like walking
through somebody else's memories that
sounds dangerous you really think this
memories
what do you have to lose
this is this is very The Evil Within if
you think about this how do I even do
this
I I don't know like trying my spores
reaching out to it
let's see what happens
gotta like really resonate with this
gotta charge up the crystals if you know
what I mean
fine
what the hell
huh
sure I'm gonna go with sure
you sing this can't be good
so weird you'll know what that means in
a little bit I think she sees things
that aren't there
creepy stay away from it imagine wanting
to be fine definitely something just
moved on her hand
shut up
freaks
[Music]
okay I think it stopped
um I'm guessing this isn't going to be
harmless and it's going to be more than
dangerous
so the story I'm assuming is going to be
something about retracing through events
that have occurred in the previous games
okay
where are you okay
if this is like The Evil Within I am
actually very excited about that because
I miss playing The Evil Within I miss
delivering soup directly into the brains
of all of my paying customers I need to
find the purifying crystals Miranda's
research claims that the mega my seat
preserves the memories of people who
passed away within its area of influence
absorbing them into its own vast
Consciousness we also know based on our
previous encounters with the mold that
people who are contaminated with the
mutami seed are connected to it in a
kind of mold network if we extrapolate
there from this we can surmise their
subjects with a strong Affinity to the
mute of my seat should be able to use
the network to connect to the memories
of the Dead within the mega my seat
that's a quite a hypothesis guys that's
a big hypothesis that's how big maybe
you're putting on that one it should be
possible to verify this Siri using the
lab's mega my seed sample we collected
16 years ago we just need a suitable
subject with a proven connection to the
mold and I'm sure that any of the
government agencies who are watching
me have not heard about this or approved
this plan unfortunately this presents a
problem our organization's policies
prevent us from directly contacting
civilians who are infected with
mutomycet
they're what more civilian Zoo certainly
the ethical reasoning is understandable
but it is rendered the confirmation of
this Theory impossible
it pains me to think of how much mankind
could stand to benefit from this
preservation and indexing of human
consciousness the possibilities of
preserving or even reclaiming great
minds perhaps there's some way of
cutting through the red tape oh
I think I think I'm the scissors I'm
pretty sure I'm the one that cuts man
I'm slow all right we'll just need to do
a lap to warm up I'm on my way now
wait hmm what yeah it's probably not
good
this is very evil within I love it I
love it I love it I love this
hi hello it's me whatever my name is
it snow or something oh
hi can we be friends we're the same you
and I we're practically the same I'm
infested with fungus you're a fungus
so much in common
extremely goopy is going on Behind These
doors
well
time to find the other civilians in the
normal populace that are infected with
this horrible fungus that takes over
people's minds and bodies I'm sure
nothing can go wrong
I'm sure nothing at all can go wrong man
this is with these games I never know I
have an instinct not to go in the first
door that I find because I'm afraid of
missing something but I don't know what
is the door that's going to miss
something or not I'll be next if I'm not
quick I need to get that Crystal
who else is who else has been in here
who
who pooped in here whose blood is this
why
also I don't know who that person was
are they my friend they don't seem like
my friend if they sent me into this
completely non-dangerous thing that
definitely no one else has been in
looking for some weird Crystal of energy
oh see this is another thing I just
don't know which way to go
oh God
well that's unpleasant
[Music]
all right so I'm guessing there's not
gonna be a name written on this shoe
well that's probably fine squash squump
all right well I guess there's nothing
here better get
who's this
it's the same as in you
can't you tell Rose
rose not snow Rose I thought I was
thinking Ethan
her
and snow
hello hi who are you
is someone there
dangerous here no why no
hang tight I'm gonna see if I can find a
key actually I'm not gonna do that
because I was informed that there is not
dangerous here and even if there was
someone said that there was dangerous
you you said that it was dangerous in
that room it's not dangerous out here so
what could be the problem
hello
squeaky
it can be a horror game without squeaky
doors
oh
Rose that's my name
oh hello
ah
I just do some pull-ups real quick I
need to get my workout in
you okay Rose
you hypnotized or something
normal behavior amongst all these what
are probably not bodies
decorative bags of trash man you could
probably start a good business if you
sold trash bags at when you film it
should filled out the shape of a human
body
is that foreshadowing I feel like this
is foreshadowing that Something's Gonna
land on top of me and if that is
I'm gonna fall victim do it because I'm
going to forget immediately I can't read
that
that's my name I can read that I was
talking about the weird script on the
never mind
you guys can just assume that I don't
know how to read to create art simply
add to the
at the
add to the rabbit's carcasses Decay is
not an issue Spruce them up with a bit
of makeup it makes him seem more alive
I don't know what you're talking about
I don't know if what you speak hello
friend
friend Darkness
darkness my old friend oh boy Whoa
conveniently placed
well that key was loud yeah
yeah
okay
all right
good ideas here that specifically right
in front of me is a good idea
laughs
what the hell is this stuff
was it trying to form a clone of me
is that the real danger here
am I the danger
am I currently the one
yes
that's goop I know goop when I see it
and that is 100 goop hey
I don't remember this being open this
way
really hoopy
like really goopy
oh extraordinarily goopy the treatment
room
how mysterious oh
a little bit
a little bit this is fine
what's that what was what did you hear
something that I didn't hear because I
didn't hear anything
ah
okay all right that's probably fine
hello I
you remember how you said that was
danger I don't know what you're talking
about it's all good here come on up
friend yeah
come on
I unlocked it did you hear me I um
oh that's funny okay
I feel like I should fight this
I feel like there should be a quick time
event or something hello
can I help you
uh
uh interesting
me
hmm
hmm who are you
I'm Rose
what's going on here hmm
let's keep moving
but must we
must we keep
no no no no no no no no no remember I
was told there is no danger you gotta
remember that there's there's no danger
none danger here
so uh I don't know what you're talking I
probably should have followed sooner I'm
I'm I feel like I'm alone
yeah wait wait
um wait up
sis
sis
sister
yeah I went I went to the uh bodies too
where are you going
what are you doing oh need help
me lift
they need a spotter don't worry uh I've
been working out for a long time I'm
very strong
anyway apparently I have superpowers so
I probably could have done that with
like a fungal thing where are you going
oh fungal strength
my my my seat strength
anyway was that your shoe I found that
that shoe looked familiar
this is concerning
oh well what are you afraid of
[ __ ] oh that's weird that
that's that's that's concerning
interesting
huh
you know uh I don't know why I trust you
and not that one well I feel like I
should help that one or something
uh but no I guess we're not doing that
oh
hi
you want out
you you you want out you you want
where'd you go where did you go oh hey
are you listening to me
to open the gate hate to open the oh
okay I thought you didn't have a head I
mean you're dead which is also a problem
but I thought you were headless and dead
which is
indicative of something that can behead
you which is a more present danger than
what I was previously experiencing I can
break that or I can jump on that I don't
know what I can need to find that handle
quickly go deeper
am I locked
okay I was just about to say if you
locked me and I would have been very
upset okay so that's a return to where I
came I don't know why that's separate
but whatever
I'm in it to win it
man I am slow is this locked or
something yeah
all right good well I seem to be in the
thick of it in the thick of the goopiest
thickest part of it
analyzing
things sound identified harmless totally
harmless not a problem here
I just needed to remember that there was
no danger oh there's no danger none
danger none danger danger zero danger
level zero absolutely no danger none
none of us this is dangerous
how are you your face
it's so not dangerous
really
did that did that really what did that
really what
did that really what switch handle uh
that's convenient
well what's back there what's what's
going on here I detect a little
something
strange
all right goodbye I'll never know
Ayah I unlocked it anybody there
no anybody there no
uh goodbye
oh
what
probably fine
probably a-okay
all right oh good you all
you got it you know you got that
[Laughter]
I don't like the fungal dementor oh no
thank you
all right I have powers
oh yeah
oh okay well we're not fighting right
now so we're just gonna do this I'm
gonna do this real slow like yeah take
your time
all right well I thought this was gonna
open oh my God I thought this was gonna
oh that's not good oh oh is it oh my God
it's
oh there's nothing I can do for any of
you
oh poor clones oh yeah yeah okay well
Ring Around The Rose oh no my pockets
are full of posies okay I'm just gonna
go you know all of my gamer instincts
are telling me that I need to go
there's no reason to stop anywhere here
because it's not dangerous
uh uh uh okay
no
it's an elevator
stay back I've got spores
foreign
hey oh I foreshadow I thought it was
gonna follow me that's not good
foreshadow
foreshadow
man why doesn't everybody have
convenient lights on their chest
this way
okay
hello
oh
all right
yep
comfortable
so when am I gonna get to the um
part where I play the other characters
you know what I mean where where where
does that come in
where does that come in
man
definitely safe here
no danger here
ah well
what are you
I believe it
what were those things
what is happening here
how what is this
where am I
well I would love to that's great advice
but also until I get this
and I'm not leaving until I do
wait a minute
who are you my guardian angel
do you have a name
if you're an angel then
Gabriel Michael
okay
Michael
what now
what happens if you rearrange the
letters of Michael
Jamel
no idea saving wrong spot
dad and oh God
it's fine every time it's fine it's fine
it's fine where am I going this way so
um what do you
um
or me's
[Music]
wait isn't that uh trade the trademan
the trader man
treaty man
[Laughter]
uh-huh
laughs
[Applause]
looks like we caught another oh boy
Lively now aren't you you should have
put that effort into running it would
have made the chase that much more
thrilling
don't let me go
it would seem this little rabbit lacks
the necessary footage
[Music]
showing a little grit and actually
escaped that purifying Crystal would now
be yours hey
the crystal
ah nope
oh no
wow that was uh let's see how fast this
one is that was truly terrible on my
part that was
that was just about the worst that it
could be also weren't you nice before
you were nice to my dad oh boy oh what's
this song Oh what is this
this chair now
all right I can do without the moaning
all right come on away I guess good
thing these are opening oh no I don't
want to get out of here
oh well that's a problem uh what now
thinking on my feet thinking on my feet
no it would never where am I going
oh wait no I shouldn't be there right
I see when you said it was grabbing on
my legs you didn't mean and you said get
out of there now I thought you might
keep going forward
I am lost
how far back am I lost how much have I
lost how lost am I
no okay it's not bad all right so take
two this time not gonna make the same
mistake twice
what if
I go
another Direction what if I go to the
left here what is over here
turns out it's locked guys guy surprise
it's locked well that guy was thrown off
couldn't possibly be stupid enough to go
that way
yay oh no
all right so definitely don't go there
I see okay do I go back in ah
of course
well out danger too
uh
a gun
perfect
seriously
I don't know if gun gonna
I don't know if gun do as much
what like this
the pen is mighty
literary joke
point and shoot I point I shoot I point
I shoot I point I shoot and I should I
shoot and I should stop moving your head
stop wiggling okay and dead can you give
me more bullets say bullets really loud
let me touch your bullet words
all right so about that
um I see
Jeff
perfect okay
so I have surroundings and I need to
explore them I don't know what that's
about but I'm sure I'll find out later
um
you got an obsession with rabbits man
you got a problem
it's gone it's lady Dimitris stairs
wow
wait
this must be the crystal can I have it
can I have
the disciples await their masks bronze
silver gold with their Garba I guess I
need to find these masks to unlock it I
was reading that is this supposed to be
like lady dominusque and her three
daughters or something like that I don't
know it's kind of weird was this here
before I don't even remember
I need to find some masks which is cool
hello anybody mask in here I'm vaguely
remembering how this game layout was I
spent a lot of time in this Castle
grant me that which sees the truth
through the three eyes or something like
that I don't know how fast this game
thinks I read but I I read that fast I
do I swear
um
I hear moaning
I hear moaning and groaning uh something
in the dining room that I missed
I'll be back well hi hey what's up you
know what I don't want to waste bullets
just yet so I don't know if I need to
kill you
but I'm gonna find out soon enough
probably so you wait right there whoa
whoa those are important oh [ __ ] wait
stop don't wait stop don't don't don't
that's my face good God that's so much
on my face why would you do that
stop that no
[Applause]
ah you could die quieter
it's an option you know
just so you know okay so I have bolt
cutters and that's really nice and half
of my face has been slurped out of me
but I don't look so bad those other
roses were just wimpy babies
over here why
if you really want to help you could
back me up against those things
yeah what so I'm on my own
great great good okay well I'll take the
ammo could you give me more is that all
you can give me
Bowl Cutters hmm nothing can see with
three eyes or whatever it is you
required okay
yeah I know that's still there oh can I
go out that way probably not
I can do that
hiya
who needs a key you got the most useful
tool in Resident Evil hello what am I
looking at
can I shoot this no
worth a bullet to try it's not a waste
if it's exploration I bet you're the
type of people that just play these
games and never use the rare items
am I that type of person I don't know
you guys would know better than me
core
what do you mean that gross lumpy thing
how am I supposed to break it
use my power powers
I literally came here to get rid of them
yep
omelets and whatnot okay
fine but how what am I supposed to do
need what's that um
well how do you know so many things
how do you know such things I'm going to
make a guess that this is probably Ethan
Winter's memories guiding his daughter
because it would be very poetic and it
would be slightly predictable of which I
am both of those things
poetic and predictable
I don't like this door
I don't like you door
you stupid door
all right I forgot that crafting was a
part of this game
I'm gonna craft up a storm
hello
oh good more goop oh no I like that
chair hmm
I could use these things and combine
them together okay should be more items
I can combine I need to do whatever to
survive who is talking
who's talking
oh
all the other rabbits
okay
well I don't know if I should stay here
if you're gonna be all goopy like that
oh this is probably not the best hey you
let her go you
that
that and one of these
okay five shots roughly kills these
dudes
uh uh one Note One ammo please thank you
did I wait a minute oh okay I did it
okay just checking that I did it sorry
if only I'd been here just moments
sooner
that's that's my bad I'm sorry me sorry
other clone of me is that a bad sound is
that about that sounds whoa holy crap
okay I don't have enough bullets for
that and I'm guessing that I probably
shouldn't count on killing everything
that I see I've got to get powers I've
got to get some goopy powers and then I
gotta be able to blast him with my hand
well that's not good all right goodbye
let me just make sure I've played a lot
of stuff
uh I can oh sick oh sick
nice
very nice oh God which way am I going
this way yeah
good thing someone pissed all over the
directions I need to go
um
piss ladder
all right well that was he I don't like
you oh I love you all right anything
here I vaguely remember being up here
before
and I think it was perfectly safe and
nothing bad happened
and also I think there was guns or
bullets or something like that
this I don't know if I trust you let me
look at this first I have found a means
of dramatically destabilizing parts of
the mute to my seat Network by
introducing a disruptive Force to block
the auto inducers they use for
communication for example the hard pack
scores of mold known as sclerotia
clear out here begin to break down on a
cellular level and disintegrate when
thus disrupted
sclerosis form when the mutomycin
develops in new locations serving as a
form sort of Anchor Point or foothold
they often are associated with the patch
of liquid void through which the mold
has spread
when the auto inducers of the sclerosa
are disrupted it begins to break down an
E-liquid void connected to this clerusha
will also disintegrate it would appear
that destabilizing the sclerosa sends a
signal indicating that location is no
longer viable for mutamized heat
habitation triggering a full-scale
retreat
well there was a lot to say that if I
just shoot the big glowy part everything
runs away like a little baby
I guess I'll just never hit one
oh
unfair unfair all right what is this new
variant
I remember that from the
from the original game
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh shut up you there was that
Jedi make the ball levitate thing
I feel
different
somehow
all right let's see if this works whoa I
got goobies am I gonna get more goopies
where um where was in recent one wait a
minute
you thought you could hide from me I
should definitely check and make sure
that I actually get everything in every
room or else I'm gonna run you I'm going
to focus on you
yeah
go Webb
ghost claro Shadow how do I do that
Focus here how do I
go
uh you don't like that do you
punk all right well that was nice
do I have a limit on that I'm guessing I
have a limit on that I probably can't
just do that forever
hey stop it yeah take some of this yeah
that's what you get
that's what you get all right well
that's oddly effective that's actually
extremely effective that seems almost
too effective
I'm not gonna question it probably fine
who needs herbs not me I am very healthy
am I very healthy I'm fine it's like off
green all right so that's all for here
and now I suddenly have magic powers
which which I can combat the demons
foreign
I nailed it with a superhero Landing
which negates all fall damage I could
have sworn that was gonna kill me I was
almost positive that was gonna kill me
who do you think you
all right
oh yeah there we go
so there's a range
there's a range but that's okay I got
the range so wait a minute who do you
think you are shut up shut up I'll kill
you who is that
who was it where I don't see anything
why oh you take some of this
all right well get a grip already oh God
it's getting a grip
all right so it's not just five head
shots it's like five roughly near the
head shots take this all right
well I can't kill those things which is
fine I wasn't expecting to Sure still
suck ass
all right
that seems handy
a noise all right I like that I did like
the customization of the game this is
one of the few Resident Evils that I
never actually went back and played all
of the different versions of it like all
the mini games and stuff and got all the
Collectibles it wasn't necessarily that
I didn't want to it said I originally
played this when I was in Canadia when I
was in Canada filming the edge of sleep
so I played it on my laptop and for some
reason the saves did not transfer over
when I got back so I would have had to
beat the whole game again on normal
which I just never got around to doing
but I don't know
[Applause]
who's a little [ __ ] baby over here stop
crying we all got problems shut up
take this you're about to have a bigger
one
now your home's gone
I burnt it down what are you gonna do
about that
thank you
oh did I get it for everything
God shut up this guy oh what do you
think of this
it seems like there's no cooldown on
that
pick that and that and that oh loser
wow you are terrible it's too bad I
don't have like a knife
I really think I should have a knife
whoa never mind
oh God
no
I'm missing
that's not like me oh God oh God stop
oh God stop
okay so headshots do matter I do need
majority of headshots to be able to kill
him you still crying shut up
I need medicine okay got that and then
Morgan powder all right I'll use it oh
sploosh I wonder why this one's in third
person the other one was in first person
I do think I like
the third person better as from a
gameplay standpoint but from a horror
standpoint I do kind of like the first
person oh
yeah I'm good
what
what
is that
just a normal thing where something
spawning or is that something else I'm
gonna find out
oh yeah
suck this
if
thank you
all right oh that was fun
oh
you're blocking my path
that's kind of stupid
what the hell is this supposed to be he
there's another mask over there
monocular door deep
basement
all right I just gotta find the
monocular door whatever that means uh
well you mean it's not he it's here
all right oops
okay I got the bronze mask that seemed
oh that was me I thought it was
okay there's more items over here though
shake some of this
[Applause]
why are you blocking that path
was it just to make me go get that photo
that shows the monocular door or
whatever it was
I mean I appreciate the guidance I
usually do get very lost very quickly
but oh I take some of this
all right so there is what is called a
monocular door over here but I don't
think that I have the
monocular key unless it's a thing where
this has one and there's a door that has
three and what I need to do is put one
mask on so that then this door opens
enjoy it I don't know you want a flask
it gave me super mushroom powers
I found whatever what I probably got to
do is I gotta go put this mask on the
other thing and then when that happens
I'll be able to progress further all
right so we got one mask and that's good
thank you everybody so much for watching
I will continue this very soon with the
second
don't make fun of me
the second and the third masks
real soon anyway it's good to be back
where's where's uh where's Lady D
where's the lady don't miss I didn't
miss her did I
I didn't miss her but I didn't miss her
did I either wait let me know in the
comments below thank you and as always I
will see you in the next video
bye-bye